[Music]
thank you and joining us now to detail
how the 210 hostage situations in France
came to an end earlier today our former
FBI Deputy assistant director Danny
Coulson and director of jihad watch
Robert Spencer uh for in terms of the
operation uh Danny let's just talk about
this simultaneous what were your
thoughts on that I think they did a good
job Sean I've trained with those guys
that's G they helped me start the FBI h
Rescue Team I've done jobs with them and
they're very very competent they have a
lot of experience uh if remember many
years ago alqaeda tried to fly Air
France playing the Eiffel Tower and they
took them down so you have to give a lot
of kudos to them I I can't say the same
thing for the pl police on the street
that they had the shooting they didn't
seem to respond very well but their CT
unit did yeah I let me turn to you if I
can um because I think this is really
important Robert Spencer because listen
you are all over the issue of jihad
and after every one of these instances
occur everybody says how could this have
happened you know everything that I've
been learning about not only France but
Europe in general tells me and I'm not
trying to be callous here that a lot of
signs were missed just like with the
9/11 commission report they were at war
with us we weren't at war with them
explain how islamists have like a
separate Society Muslims have a separate
Society from the rest of France
absolutely Sean look the the Muslim
immigrants in France and all over Europe
are unprecedented there has never been
in the history of the world before
large-scale immigration of a people from
one place to another with a ready-made
model of society and governance that
they consider to be superior to the
model of the place to which they are
coming they have no interest in
integration no interest in assimilation
all they want to do is islamize and
transform the society that they're
coming to so in France they have set up
the the French government lists on a
public website 750 1 no-o areas where
essentially the police have no Authority
the French state has no Authority and
Islamic law prevails these places are
incubators of it almost reminds me like
sort of like Israel they're allowing
themselves to be surrounded now you say
why then if they don't want to
assimilate to Western culture which
their value system is the antithesis
it's freedom of speech and expression
and religion Etc if they don't want to
assimilate to that why do they even go
there is it because they want is this
part of a desire for world wide
domination in this caliphate Sean it is
I mean imig they want immigration is a
core Islamic principle the idea of the
HRA the flight from Mecca to Medina
where Muhammad for the first time became
a political military and as well as a
spiritual leader and began to conquer
Arabia from there that Sanctified in
Islam the idea of immigrating to a new
place to conquer and islamize it and
that's exactly what we're seeing so the
idea is for those that are radical Islam
they want to integrate this worldwide so
they move to other areas and rather than
assimilate their goal is to indoctrinate
and proze and if necessary through Force
change absolutely they set up these
Sharia enclaves and then because their
birth rate is so much higher than that
of the non-muslim population those
enclaves will inevitably grow and
continue to grow until finally that's
all there is Danny Coulson from a law
enforcement standpoint is a former FBI
Deputy assistant director
do you agree with that assessment and if
that's true how do how does the Western
World stop that well I think that's
about the best assessment I've ever
heard of the problem that was a great
job well what you've done there is
you've allow a lot of cancer to come
inside your country it's almost like the
Vietnam term they're inside the wire
that's where you don't want them and it
greatly inhibits law enforcement to uh
to conduct an investigations there if
you can't go there how do you
investigate uh terrorism you can't do it
I I think it's a bad situation
and it seems like it's about time to me
that France took their country back I
can't even imagine having a force inside
your country that you do not control
that's just so wait a minute so if
France has 6 and a half million Muslims
10% of the population estimates vary a
little bit a million here or there okay
you say take back a country what does
that mean that either you allow us into
these areas you allow our police in you
don't have non-muslim zones where where
non-muslims aren't allowed or noo
you're saying that all of a sudden
they're going to change that what's
going to happen if they try to I don't
think they're going to change it all of
a sudden but I think they cannot let it
extend um Sean we're in a war and we
have to fight a war like it's a war and
if we have the Enemy Inside the gates I
think you address it through law
enforcement through the military
whatever it takes to get your country
back I can't even imagine a situation
like that and how difficult it would be
to control your country and soon or
later they're going to lose control of
it 751 no goes on what are we going to
go in all of a sudden and say I'm sorry
we're policing now and here's the
question is this happening in the United
States yes it is that's on a much much
smaller scale of course in theed States
because the Muslim population of the
United States is much smaller we have no
go zones in the United States well you
know in in the United States you have
more you have the those camps way out in
the country at least 35 have been
documented where they are essentially
like those nogo zones but they're not in
urban areas and in concentrated places
talking about specifically I'm talking
about I'm sorry areas of Michigan yeah
sure Michigan but uh I'm talking about
rural areas New York Georgia South
Carolina California places that are way
out and remote you have these Islamic
enclaves where the same kind of
situation prevails there was uh there
was some disturbances at some of them in
Texas not uh last year and uh the police
showed the same hesitation about going
in that they show in France all right
guys thank you both appreciate it